what exactly are white people good at
that is a question being asked in a
video that has gone very viral on a huge
youtube channel i think it has something
like
10 million subscribers to this channel
this
is the current embodiment of the
orwellian concept
of two minutes hate of dehumanizing
people
of suppressing one's own empathy trying
to stamp out one's own empathy
ironically in the name of equity and
justice
and compassion the video opens up with a
simple question what are white people
superior at they're asking
people who i think they're all black but
you know some i don't know
race is sometimes a blurry thing so who
knows but i guess at least the premises
that this outlet is asking black people
what are white people superior at it
starts out
funny enough what exactly are white
people superior at oh well according to
television everything
white man could fly even a white woman
she could be four foot one she knew
karate she could take down 15 people
[Music]
what are white people superior at
man
[Music]
oh god what are white people superior
at they they just keep talking
mostly about their pets white people
love gay dogs like that's
all you see cats letting them get on
your countertops while you're cooking
yes i get that you love your pet black
you need to take it everywhere
like everywhere i guess you know hey
emotional support animals i guess
what exactly are white people superior
men like making cereal casseroles what
kind of casserole
tuna it's always tuna what do you mean
it's always tuna
using mayonnaise in a lot of their
recipes
making bland food counting season
chicken okay so
it starts out funny enough it's kind of
an interesting
aspect of the video that a number of
these people are obviously
part white i mean they're obviously some
people would be indistinguishable
from white people but they identify
maybe they're a mixed race or something
like that
as many many people are but they
identify as black and they identify sort
of against
being white even even if they are in
part white but you know i think these
comments are actually pretty
funny what are white people good at i
don't know making cereal yes
it's true white people do prefer cereal
uh you know
what about people what are they good
superior at all making tuna casserole
with lots of mayonnaise yeah that's true
guilty as charged i do i love a tuna
melt
call me i know i'm a little swarthy to
be a wasp but i do okay that's kind of
that's kind of funny of course there's a
hypocrisy here because if another
channel went out and asked the question
what are black people
superior at and they gave any answers
similar to this about food or anything
else
you know the makers of that video would
be canceled they would be ostracized
they would probably be sent away from
the country and banished
they would lose their job it would be
called racist and white supremacists
sure there's that hypocrisy but i'm just
judging on the quality of the video
itself
yeah it's kind of funny white people do
take their dogs too many places it
drives me absolutely insane and it's
almost always white people on the little
planes with the little yappy things
it in the restaurants now all these
millennial white women pretend that
there are little poodles or little mini
poodles or
emotional support animals it is
ridiculous it's a funny thing we can
laugh at that okay but then the video
takes a turn
because then it stops being about these
funny cultural and racial
differences then it becomes
about resentment white people are great
at having fun that's a function of
white supremacy because they just don't
have as many stresses
as we do white people are very superior
at their privilege in utilizing it we do
not have the privilege to do
whatever and however we want to what
exactly are white people superior at
uh not getting arrested yeah i was
driving down the street
with uh down the highway with a friend
of mine who was white when he was like i
need to i'm just going to pull over and
pee
and i'm in the passenger seat and i was
like please don't because the black man
thinks differently if i pull over to the
side of the road and pee
a cop is going to be right behind me to
punish me
what exactly are white people superior
insecurity pretending
fear being fearful of nothing being
ignorant
blame letting their egos control their
every move privilege
truly chilling victimized playing the
victim congratulating themselves over
that they're incompetent at or that
should have already been done
they're superior at being
whoa that's some pretty bigoted stuff
right there isn't it these people are
pretty
vicious racial bigots aren't they this
stops being funny all of a sudden
these actually are bigots i mean the
things they're saying are are deeply
bigoted and wrong and immoral
and the thing about it is just like with
all bigots it's not even
necessarily the case that they're wrong
about the other guy andrew clavin makes
this point a lot
the thing about bigots that we all get
wrong is it's not that they're
necessarily wrong about
what they're saying about the other guy
it's that they're wrong about themselves
they don't recognize
that they have the problems that they're
accusing these people that they despise
of having
one of the lines here is that white
people are really good at playing the
victim
the entire premise of this video is to
play the victim right so obviously if
you're going to
accuse the other guy that while you were
doing it yourself there is
some hypocrisy there and then one of the
lies of this video is they're pretending
that this is a racial distinction
primarily which and i guess it might be
in the case of they don't like white
people
but it's not a racial distinction in who
is making the video
they're trying to pretend that this
group of performers
are representative of black people
they're not
one of these guys was wearing an angela
davis t-shirt angela davis
is one of the most infamous communists
in the country
another guy was wearing a t-shirt that
said dismantle
these are not an uh random sampling of
black americans these are
radical radical leftists some of the
most radical of all of them
right they were talking about cr people
with kind of crazy
political ideologies uh sort of
represented in sort of crazy
outfits because the one thing that the
left is trying to do
in particular is suppress this idea that
black people
are permitted to think for themselves
clarence thomas made this point during
the the anita hill hearings in the early
1990s
he when he described his confirmation
process as a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way deigned to
think for themselves
president trump has been saying since
2016 come on leave the left they haven't
done anything for you
and he made huge inroads among the black
population i don't think any of those
black americans were permitted to be in
this video
what the left is trying to do is
contrive and gin up racial resentment
to affect their political goals they
don't care about
black people at all or any other racial
group what they care about is that
angela davis picture what they care
about
is the ideology that she represents
radical leftism and then they say they
have the audacity
to say in this video that
uh what one thing white people are very
superior at is controlling the narrative
what exactly are white people superior
making us believe that
we don't matter believing that they're
superior feeling superior taking their
superior thinking that they're superior
thinking that they are superior
self-delusion controlling the narrative
believing their own press
marketing of white superiority whether
you are republican whether you're
difficult whether you're conservative
like white people are really good
at upholding white supremacy how about
claiming that you know they are actually
a whole separate race
when actually white dna comes from the
black female
hold on a second i'm not i'm not going
to make the biological
uh question i'm not going to take the
biological question seriously of whether
or not i came from a black female i mean
i did come from a sicilian female who is
darker than
probably most people in this country but
regardless of that point you've just
spent the whole video
castigating white people as a race we
talked about this yesterday
white i racial consciousness is very
very low in this guy
pew research showed this white racial
consciousness is something like 15
every other race that's over 50 so yeah
i don't i don't think about
whiteness or being white or anything
like almost ever
but you can't make a whole video saying
white people are terrible white people
are oppressive white people do this why
people do that and also they think
they're a race
no i don't you think so you're the one
making that argument the left
is the one making that argument because
it's politically advantageous but
controlling the narrative every
institution in america has spent
millions of dollars practically
and has spent nine months uttering the
phrase black lives matter
you couldn't you could never make this
kind of a video
in the other direction but of course you
can in in
this direction and it gets it gets way
worse than that we'll skip around but it
ends on a point that the left is always
trying to make it's an orwellian point
for that matter
it it makes this whole racist
bigoted awful kind of argument the whole
video
and then they try to end on an
egalitarian
tone of equality just because our
skin color is different you're no better
than me you know smarter than me
no no superiority there
no superiority yeah okay no one is
making the claim that white people
are superior and you know they are
that's a flat statement white people are
superior
but this video is making the claim that
white people are inferior
on the basis of their race that's not
egalitarian at all
there's nothing there's no reason anyone
should take that seriously
if this were in the other direction that
channel would be taken off of youtube
right now
perhaps it should be i don't know i
don't know i mean i'm i'm all for uh for
hearing out various points of view the
left certainly isn't though
imagine if that were in the other
direction i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you